[Applause]
[Music]
hey
oh hey man welcome back to fat man
beyond him kevin smith i am mark bernard
hey
kids holy crap man we were supposed to
be doing this
at the scum and villainy uh
cantina uh right there in hollywood on
hollywood boulevard but uh we uh the
plans had to switch kids
um so here we are
doing it from home but either way
[ __ ] free just like your generation
on the internet has come to expect
nobody's sick like that wasn't the
reason why we we changed it there's a
lot of speculation oh which one that
calls it
i don't know
really was there people did people
speculate yeah yeah what happened what
went wrong what is it
um i was just tested i mean aside from
having the vaccinations the two shots
and then having had the booster already
um i just got tested
again
yesterday because i was in a
short film today for luke who runs our
website stuff uh he directed a short
that i got to act in so i'm i'm [ __ ]
clean kids i'm i'm i'm jabbed and i'm
tested and whatnot so
i could be in the room with you all but
thank god i'm
i'm anywhere
to be honest with you i'm just happy to
be here ready to talk shop how are you
good friend what's uh going on in your
world uh i'm doing well man i'm doing
well busy
busy this this was one of those weeks
where you know so much of of this job
which is you know working as a writer in
hollywood is just juggling things right
it's like well you never know which one
of these are going to go which one of
these are going to get the green light
which one these are going to start
paying you for
so you keep like five or six things in
some steady series and and pattern in
the sky
right um and then hopefully if it works
out right they land one at a time and so
you can give each one it's due attention
this was one of those weeks where like
three of them started falling out of the
sky
and so it's oh i gotta do that oh and i
have to do that i want to turn on this
for that and oh this needs to happen oh
oh
oh
so uh so yeah it's been from from like
last thursday to tomorrow
it was a day it was it's been a it's
been a brace
of chaos
but it's coming to an end and so now i
got fuel in all these planes and they're
going back into the sky and they will
or you know
you can't tell anybody what you're
working on either that's the frustrating
part like
it'd be one thing if it was like oh man
it's been one of those weeks but guess
what kids i'm working on
you don't even get to share that aspect
though no but it's like we're writing
like audition sides for actors to start
you know reading for roles which is
always super exciting
but i can't say what it's for i can't
say you know what kind of actors we're
looking for but it's
it's fun
it's getting real
hey man i got a little inside [ __ ]
dope
what you got
can't say where it's
where i got it from but uh let me let me
uh read it to you man it's pretty
insight into uh a world that we dearly
know and love uh the world of course of
marvel films
um and this you know i don't think this
threatens
uh anything they do or or whatnot but
it's you know
i thought it was an interesting
factoid come from inside the world
uh
threw up many sources i can't even
tell you but pretty legit
ain't a spoiler so if you're like
you know i got enough no news about
daredevil or anything like that
this is just i found this interesting
uh
there is a marvel secret police
who when things are being discovered
you know not only sweat down the
department so when leaks happen
not only do the marvel secret police
like sweat all the departments to find
out where the leaks sprang from they
also
deal in subterfuge and we know this in
as much as you'll go to auditions and
read lines that have nothing to do with
what you're auditioning for
so they're well practiced at the art of
like look over here you know they like
to keep their secrets over there so
they leave leftover
call sheets
where they draw illusions to characters
that are well known that don't exist so
they lay
little traps in the call sheets to see
if it gets passed on and then try to
find
the leaks thusly like
this is some watergate level [ __ ] man
of thought that goes into like we got to
keep these secrets like meanwhile we're
living in a world where like the most
open secret on the planet is there's 96
spider-men in the next spider-man
and everyone's like don't tell the
secret but we all know it and stuff but
how fascinating man like
the marvelous police the uh the spy
craft at work because i'm sure it's also
every department will get a different
fake name that they're dropping so that
if that's the name and services of the
press they know where it leaked from
like the costume department got thanos
and this department got crank and this
department got draxed and this farmer
got whatever and so whichever one of
these names is how you discover where
the link is there's a like an old
practice i used to do because i you know
i just keep my scripts real quiet and
[ __ ] and now nobody gives a [ __ ] so you
know i could post them on the internet
still nobody cares but back in the day
you know you print them on that paper
with the red line through it and then
you
print them like with people's name and
they still do that they print people's
name onto every page but the trick that
we always used to do is change one word
per draft that went out so that way if
that you know you wound up with a copy
online and that were you know almost
like a safe word like [ __ ] pineapple
somewhere in the script where it really
doesn't appear in any other script and
then you could really track down
you know where the leak sprang from or
something like that and never really had
to use it or anything but like
overly
cautious but you know let's let's be
honest nobody gives a [ __ ] about my [ __ ]
as much as they do
marvel like even i would [ __ ] you
know be tempted to be like i'm gonna
[ __ ] try to find [ __ ] out is this a
[ __ ] leftover call sheet oh my god
galactus
like i'm a total pigeon they catch me
just like that yeah you know they're
also really smart and really good about
and i remember when they did it with
iron man 3
where we thought we were getting the
mandarin
you know and then the bait and switch
was oh wait is it gonna be is is
is it is it
is ben kingsley playing the mandarin and
like he was everywhere and we bought it
and then it was no he's playing trevor
slattery an actor who's been told to act
like he's the manager and the real bad
guy over here is guy pierce it's the
answer the question the audience isn't
asking yet so then they won't actually
look to answer the one that they're
going to want
like give them something and so the fact
that we're getting a dozen spider-man is
probably not the big [ __ ] thing
in spider-man 3 it's probably something
else because they already gave us this
we're already chewing on that we're
already like what do they get a little
spider-man
you think there's something even more
surprising than [ __ ] like here's all
three spider-man
whipping together and [ __ ]
uh dollars to donuts yeah
you got a lot of faith in the in the
system my friend i love marvel but i'm
like
what's bigger news than like we got them
all back yes we got them all back for
the last year you've been guessing and
yes you're absolutely right
um
you know unless
somebody [ __ ] dies or something like
that
i have no idea i have no insight to this
but just they're awfully good at keeping
secrets because they don't want to you
made me i was already [ __ ] like in
like flynn for [ __ ] spider-man far
far from no no way home
but you [ __ ] made me that much harder
man
you found some blood in my body to push
put it all pushing it all forward and
tie it off and
one of these things man and
i'm i'm very turgid is what i'm getting
at i like the notion that there's
something in the spider-man movie the
spider-man movie coming up that i don't
know yet
bam i mean
oh look who's here everybody it's
everybody's favorite local hero it's
banff man
uh nobody's talking about mephisto
anymore
they're not and that is when mephisto
appears [ __ ]
that's when you forget him the greatest
trick mephisto ever pulled is making
people forget think he don't exist i
think i think i just coined that phrase
more i think it's great i think you
should copyright tm that [ __ ]
i will it's too late to include in my
bookmark kevin smith's
secret stash now available like
everywhere particularly on amazon.com or
inside editions but i got a fat version
of this we had a book event at the
chinese theater last night how'd that go
absolutely lovely it was so lovely like
um you know i'd already signed the books
and
the pandemic error the book the idea of
like hey let me hear i'm going to touch
a thing and you touch it you know that's
kind of my way so the book's already
pre-signed so it was really more of a q
a show and i got up and i read from some
of the sections of the book as well but
it was absolutely lovely because i read
from the epilogue of the book which
talks all about like how when me and jay
put our feet in the cement so we were
doing it right there at the chinese
theater which was kind of kind of
awesome wonderful crowd though had a
great great time but that book is out
there in the world kids totally
available
thick as a dick and heavier than [ __ ]
you know most russian [ __ ] novels
so many photos so many [ __ ] stories
uh check it out if you're so inclined if
you know any more kevin smith fans left
if you're like i think i ran into one
once like eight months ago
this would be the perfect gift for them
at christmas time to say i know you but
i don't really care but this book 65
bucks so i must care something
that's a book mark it's very pricey yeah
it's like for the for the cousin who's a
fan
it's like you know he needs that
i mean who's that tight with their
[ __ ] cousin this is more like you
know it's my sibling as a fan and we're
too old for christmas gifts and you know
but hey i i you know i remember we went
and saw them all rats together so here
here you go
excellent i'm excited
what a great sell of that book man i'm
like
it's for like people that kind of
remember you gotta really like kevin
smith you invest in this book man it's
i'm telling you
anybody you know what they're not the
sponsor of the show tonight however i
believe we do have a sponsor don't wait
we do we do we have uh we have the good
folks at blue chew oh chew on this kids
the good folks at bluechew.com
are uh kindly enough to sponsor the
adventures of mark and kevin on
tonight's episode of fat man beyond
what's blue chew you ask not a hard
question
nice thank you well played i almost
dropped a little bluetooth when we were
getting you a little harder for uh for
[ __ ] spider-man i'm gonna sprinkle a
little blue chew right on top of it that
would have been the time to jump in and
speaking with my sponsor bluetooth
uh tell these good folks at home
what
blue chew does for everybody
blue chew is a unique online service
that delivers the same active
ingredients as viagra and seattle's but
in chewable tablets that are fraction of
the cost you can take them any time day
or night so you can plan ahead or be
ready whenever an opportunity arises
the process is simple sign up at
bluetooth.com consult with one of their
licensed medical providers and once
you're approved you'll receive your
prescription within days
it's all online no visits to doctor's
offices no awkward conversations about
your dick and no waiting in line with
the pharmacy
awkward can you like
with a doctor is the only place in the
world you can comfortably discuss your
dick and know that nobody's going to be
offended right
you would hope
but you know not every doctor is as
non-judgmental as the others even a dick
doctor is like i don't want to hear
about your dick you know like that's
your specialty that's why i came here i
don't want no dick talking here well
it's more like you rolled up into urgent
care and i was like hey uh my dick's
funny but we don't want to talk about
your dick sir
roll up together be like yo anyone got
one of these
this is [ __ ] up right you got one this
is neat man
step aside please it's like i've been
pushing rope all week i need some help
uh if you're looking for a little help
kids blue chew
that's what they're offering here man
and they're offering it to you in such
an easy way they come to you you ain't
got to go to them it's tasty from what i
understand man it's not like you know
suck down this pill choke it down get
some liquid you get to chew have a good
time you're like oh that's tasty and
then
so if you could benefit from extra
confidence when it's time to perform
blue chew can help and we've got a
special deal for our listeners try
bluetooth free when you use promo code
fat man at checkout just pay five
dollars shipping that's bluechu.com
promo code fatman to receive your first
month for free visit bluetooth.com for
more details and important safety
information and we thank bluechu for
sponsoring this podcast we don't thank
blue chew for sponsoring this podcast we
are [ __ ] slobberingly grateful that
the good folks of blue chew continue to
show faith in us and think that
somebody in our audience must be buying
a lot of bluetooth whoever you are
thank
you because
they keep coming back to us i don't know
if it's one person or if it's an army of
you but my lord man the only reason
they're interested in us is because
you're interested in them so that's
that's good news indeed there may be
there's one person whose significant
other is incredibly happy that we offer
a good promo code could just be somebody
who's like [ __ ] y'all i just like the
taste
you know
these are my starbursts so
everything else is a bonus
a boner bonus yes
um how uh how are you sir other than uh
you know work spinning many plates and
whatnot i'm good i'm good i was i was
hoping to try to get out to the movies
uh this past week
um not necessarily because i'm dying to
go see venom too
but
everybody else seems like they were
because that movie made a [ __ ] ton of
money in the box office
i was there
you went i did i saw that uh you know we
did the book signing event at the
chinese theater
um so are they
the day before we had the book signing
event i went to the chinese uh and you
know now man like it's crazy like you
know chinese theater has always been
incredibly iconic to me me and jay got
to put our footprints in there two years
ago it's coming up on the two year
anniversary um but thanks to claire man
claire at um
at legion m
and she got that place wired like around
around her pinky and stuff like that
she's out at new york comic con now
working new york comic con coming up
this week but
you know she'd been locked down over in
england for a long time she came to
america by way from dubai she's like i
could come from dubai i can't come from
europe until like next month or some so
[ __ ] so she was able to come here after
she quarantined in dubai for like three
weeks
um but
my god like for somebody who's not even
from here she's from england
she has the [ __ ] chinese theater like
so wired like they they'll take you
places that i didn't know existed that
place is a labyrinth with gorgeous
architecture and beautiful vip rooms
where like you know the main room the
chinese like i'm not talking about the
six because they've got a vip section
i'm talking about like the big
you know iconic chinese theater there
are [ __ ] balconies
yes that are so [ __ ] hidden i never
knew is up past the projection i believe
so essentially when you sit in these
balconies you see like you know the
thing that's at the top of the ceiling
the ornamentation he's literally [ __ ]
right there man it's an incredible
[ __ ] view so claire was able to hook
that up you know a sign of books and i
was like i was thinking about going to
see venom she was like oh my god we
could totally hook that up and her in
the chinese theater were like oh we'll
give you guys the vip booth so uh me
claire uh red she went and stuff a
couple people want to see the [ __ ]
flick and uh you know it
it's massive big screen to see it on and
stuff i think it was like 2d imacs which
is kind of like
you know why why not why i get i mean
that's imax right technically
most of the time it's 2d it's just huge
yeah yeah 3d is when they're really like
[ __ ] it ain't big enough in your
[ __ ] face
um so long i mean there's a long braggy
[ __ ] hey i know things and people in
[ __ ] access way of saying
uh that i have seen venom colon let
there be carnage was there anything it
did make a lot of money uh it was 90
minutes mark
so say what you will about it and many
people said many things but
jeff's kiss
for like knowing you know look
this is fun we know you can only stretch
the symbiote
so far
so 90 minutes and out you know somebody
who makes tight movies i respected that
right now
venom is shorter than clerk's three
so it tells you that andy circus is the
far better filmmaker than i am
um it's uh you know it's did you like
venom
uh me personally not especially
well boy i can't say that you're
necessarily gonna enjoy
this much more you know they take the
concept everything that you thought was
fun about it and and kind of
let's do it again but shorter
and
bring carnage into it you know and so
you got uh
woody woody harrelson coming in who i
remember the end of the last movie had
curly hair but here they the curly hair
doesn't play he's got his hair cut okay
um you know continues to be
fun little
tom hardy
project he [ __ ] wrote or come up with
a story co-wrote this one with uh
somebody else he's deeply invested in it
and obviously giving it
uh his all and and you know there's
there's [ __ ] that legit made me laugh
out loud
you know there's a lot of chicken jokes
in the [ __ ] thing
um and his [ __ ] one of the one of the
you know they of course i don't think
i'm spoiling anything to tell you that
eventually venom and carnage will fight
mark shut up
and uh one of the you know the ultimate
line the [ __ ] coup de gras
uh line was like
pretty [ __ ] wonderful like made me
literally laugh out loud in the theater
uh and then if i'm sure it's unavoidable
i don't think i'm spoiling anything
because it's all over the [ __ ]
internet and stuff but
their mid-credit sequence
you know post-credit mid-credit sequence
whatever you call
uh
teaser was
you know do you know what it is
i i don't but the fact that you've now
seen this movie means that i don't have
to as part of my job as a co-host of fat
man beyond
so i would not ruin my life if you spoil
it
uh well just in case there are folks out
there they're like [ __ ] you it just came
out i don't want it ruined and stuff i
mean i assumed anyone who cares about
this kind of [ __ ]
has spoiled it by reading the articles
on the internet let's turn to
chat and see if [ __ ] anybody gives a
[ __ ] if we talk about this
uh
not that i see
uh
so if you don't want to know kids
people are going spoil it please i don't
want to spoil it but like again i've
read i it was spoiled for me before i
saw the movie i read an article about it
and i was like oh [ __ ]
uh and to be fair the article was like
spoilers spoiler spoilers
um give a countdown like we'll count
down from five and if you don't want to
know just [ __ ]
yeah no now there's a lot of people
going don't spoil it don't spoil it
you know what i won't spoil it but you
tell me i don't know how people don't
[ __ ] know this like it is literally
all over the internet the day the movie
came out
that was the big story
and you know people were like this
overshadows everything you know so
whatever i'll let you draw your own
conclusions but that you know was very
for you know we we went on an adventure
for 90 minutes
and that post-credit sequence was like
wait
can we can that be can we see that movie
like right now
um
yeah i'm like here i i enjoyed the first
venom very much i saw it at home i
didn't see it in a movie theater and
when i saw it at home i was like [ __ ] i
wish i'd watch this [ __ ] in a movie
theater and stuff
um i i enjoyed this but i feel like i
probably enjoyed it a [ __ ] ton more had
i watched it at home not like being out
of the house was like such a harrowing
experience but like
you know it would have been awesome to
pause it and take a [ __ ] [ __ ] grab a
drink come back just all that normal
[ __ ] wear my
pajamas just like sack out in the
[ __ ] bed pet the dog while it's going
on explain to the dog who carnage is and
why this is so cool and [ __ ]
wonder aloud with the dog because my
wife never would have watched this i
promised you
wonder aloud with the dog if if you know
shriek is going to look like
[ __ ] shriek like are they going to go
full symbiote look or not and you know
stuff like that but
for
how i saw it
you know look i saw it in [ __ ]
chinese theater from a vip booth
looking down at the screen from above it
was pretty glorious way to see it that
being said
what beats your own bedroom mark like i
don't know
i mean i know what beats my bedroom
which is almost every place else but
your bedroom is something different
i i like i like my one of my favorite
things in the world to do
in my bed in my bedroom ironically is
not [ __ ]
it's eat and watch movies
because that's the other thing like i
have chinese theater i can't eat veggie
grill i mean i guess i could have
because they like
this way sir you know whatever but i
don't want to be that guy but like you
know at home i can [ __ ] i can order
postmates to arrive every half hour
throughout the movie so at every half
hour man we got like surf and turf
action going like i could try a bunch of
different things trying hummus over here
a little veggie grill over here oh
what's this beans and rice over here
you're like i like to visit a lot of
countries at once mark and they don't do
that at the snack bar
so
every half an hour foods out of coming
in or going out
so
true
um but yeah it was uh you know again
here look
maybe this is a cop out of a review but
i did direct cop out so i guess it goes
to that side
um i he made a better [ __ ] movie than
i could have
that's saying something
i guess is it i mean
you've seen my body work that's it's a
low bar mark
um here i'll say this
um
let there be carnage i put a question
mark at the end of that one oh
like well and what does carnage say to
you right i mean other than like the
character
like body count right body cam
and
i was i was actually
like
surprised at the
at the body count the timidity of let
there be carnage
you know i just you know
the character is just like he's up he's
a [ __ ] serial killer before he gets a
symbiote in him and [ __ ] so what happens
when he gets one you know so you're like
oh he turns his hand into a [ __ ]
cleaver this giant axe the pendulum
we've seen it and stuff
so you know in a world where and i'm not
saying every movie has to be this but in
a world where it was that [ __ ]
kingsman movie where they went into
church and [ __ ] slaughtered everybody
it's a pretty high bar for a comic book
movie where you know you're like all
right carnage could do this and he
didn't
he swung it it was very very cool don't
get me wrong but you know
like
didn't connect
i mean you know it's just
again no complaints but it's just like
could you imagine him just
having people
you know and you get away with it in
this movie like they got a real sense of
humor about death and violence in this
movie
but um you know
that's enough fun
uh did you see the uh i think today it
dropped the first peacemaker footage
from james gunn's peacemaker television
program i was torn between watching that
and watching the succession clip that
they put up
um because i was shooting a little short
film today so like i had to i was
between takes and stuff so i watched
succession and then i thought i'd have
enough time to watch peacemaker and then
they were like we're back in so long
story short
i have not seen it how is it
um it's it's small it's literally just a
scene where where john cena as
peacemaker
walks from his car into a diner to sit
down with some of the
the people we saw in wallers command
center like steve a g and a couple yeah
yeah
the other folks
and like it's it's
fine enough there's just there's no meat
there it's just them asking him it's
like don't know why do you leave the
house and the cosplay is coming this is
a cosplay it's a uniform i need to
stretch it out to make it fit better so
when i go to action it doesn't snag or
whatever
it's uh it is less a trailer in that
it's not a trailer at all as much as
it's like a minute long clip of a scene
which isn't remarkable other than oh all
right he looks the same
so that's cool
i i get i gotta double check hold on let
there
be carnage somebody in chat said it was
pg-13
let me see
uh
i can't
hold on hmm
i went to the wikipedia entry um what a
boring show this is people like look at
this [ __ ] old man
goddamn luddite and [ __ ] like that hey
bamf man what the [ __ ] this seems like
something should be on
what was let there be carnage rated
pg-13
is did you see that on the internet yeah
well then there you go mark that makes
sense
i thought i was wasn't the last one
r-rated
i believe it was
how strange because i went in there
going like wow i guess like you know
this is a soft car but they didn't go
for an hour
that's why
there was not as much carnage as i was
thinking there would be yes
some guy in chat was like he ate the
priest as if i'm like oh that's the most
metal [ __ ] thing you could do in an
r-rated movie but in a pg-13 movie
venom was also pg-13 so they were oh
no i thought that movie was r
that's well the internet says it's pg-13
so it must be true yeah
i mean it doesn't surprise me only in
that these are spider-man spin-offs
yeah but i thought that was the big
thing we're like well they're never
going to put them in a movie together
because this one cusses
holy [ __ ] like what an idiot i should
not be co-hosting a pop culture talk
show if i don't even [ __ ] know that
venom was pg-13
so that negates my entire like rebuttal
or my entire addendum of like there
could have been more carnage mark there
could not have been more carnage they
gave us as much
there was a ceiling for the carnage so
really the title should have been like
venom colon a ceiling for carnage
uh well i just feel that like you should
skip the mpaa category the next showdown
you compete in
yeah maybe maybe ratings is not your jam
so crazy man i will maybe maybe did is
it possible
jc tell kevin he missed everyone saying
spoil it um no i saw everyone saying
spoil it but i did see a lot of people
saying don't spoil it and you know
you don't want to rob somebody of their
potential joy there's a bleak life out
there kids and a bunch of people in chat
indicated that that little surprise was
all they had coming to them this week
i'm [ __ ] with that i'm taking
anybody's joy i ain't stealing their
sunshine len back the [ __ ] off
um
let me ask you this mark yes
this squid game
this good game
have you finished it i have not i i was
making great guns peasy piece of [ __ ]
you [ __ ] like got me all hard with it
last week so much so i ran the [ __ ] home
and told my wife oh we're watching squid
game and at least thank god to your
credit not only did i love it i know i'd
love it based on your description but
she [ __ ] went for it too man yeah big
bad way she [ __ ] loved it i mean like
it's no surprise the whole world seems
to be embracing squid game based on the
articles in my [ __ ] feed on google
and stuff but
it's i guess it's the number one netflix
show of all time at this point uh it
seems to be and i think it is currently
the most watched show
on television in any
any way you can measure it
it is the the thing that is swallowing
all
scripted television at the moment yeah
like i started watching it was making
great guns and then like my wife was
like hey have you heard of the squid
game and like yeah i'm like halfway done
you gotta wait for me
you know what you should because i'm
telling you it's like
i don't know i don't know why but it
really appeals to married couples man
i think we sit there and be like oh yeah
i'd [ __ ]
if it came down to me or you you'd be me
[Laughter]
but yeah we both [ __ ] went for it and
just binge the [ __ ] out of it like you
know not no dilite watching like you
where it's like oh i'll watch a little
here and a little there [ __ ] everyone
[ __ ] [ __ ] off you know told the kid get
out of here you bored the dogs and just
did this [ __ ] and read it you know not
like [ __ ] like let's put on those
easy
uh us uh [ __ ] voiceovers
for the pure read of it all man except
the pure read apparently
is the false translation did you did you
read any of this stuff no so what the
voice over is the real
neither apparently you're great like
there were some native korean speakers
who would go on tik tok and say
the line they're saying here
is not at all what the translation is
like they're missing the spirit of these
scenes
and and so i think what they did was
they dubbed it to match the voice
patterns right like
we we don't want to have them speaking
when the guy wasn't speaking so they
dubbed it first and then translated it
off of the dub
and not off of the original dialogue
and so apparently there are just some
whole
like complete themes and underpinnings
and tenors of scenes that are wrong
because they were translated poorly
uh in chat xavier kampong said uh
koreans are thriving right now one day
us filipinos will have our shine let me
tell you something you got your shine
filipinos don't you worry about it but
he's right
like amazing media coming out of korea
right now
yeah south korea north korea they don't
know what they're doing
i mean north korea might have the most
amazing [ __ ] that they're just not sure
you know to be fair the images of of
their leader looking thin are pretty
impressive shots i guess but not not the
impressive media that i'm talking about
coming out of
south korea man like [ __ ] from
parasite to this good lord yeah i mean
it's it's weird given that you know so
much of tv is is prestige tv right it's
it's your successions it's your your
house of the dragons it's your we're
spending a load of money to do the crown
you know to sort of you know
to be shiny and erudite and aristocratic
in a way um queen's gambit like it's
refined in television
squid game is not that squid game is
incredibly well done and it's incredibly
well performed and cast and the
production design is amazing but the
reason why we're watching squid game is
because the idea is just so crystalline
perfect
and then they've wrapped it around like
really emotional stories and really
compelling characters and
yeah like it's it's not madmen and it's
not trying to be it's trying to be pope
but like the best version of pope
trying to be battle royale
battle royale and old boy is like a
blender in the old boy as well
yeah the the people who are kidnapped
against their will kind of and taken to
a place where they're imprisoned kind of
and then forced to compete in games
um
let me ask you this man shoot
you still
uh are you still
swinging the lasso
i'm still swinging on that so very hard
effect yeah one more episode i know i'm
sad i know it's a bummer because they'll
go away for like what a year or some so
[ __ ] i mean i know they were
i think they're shooting again no or
maybe they're back in the writers room
because they got a two-season order
so it's not like we have to wait for
them to decide to pick up the show again
it's no we took a break we took a
vacation we went back to work so
hopefully it won't be that long of a
wait but
remains an amazing show i absolutely
absolutely [ __ ] adore it um i noticed
on disney plus they put up
hail to the king the uh or whatever the
short with ben kingsley yeah yeah
you know that tied into the mandarin
that was on like one of the dvds or
blu-rays at one point yeah i feel like
it was an iron man 3 blue uh dvd extra
and then like vanished
because i think there was some
questionable
like
asian asian-american
content i haven't seen it since but it
got a little bit of hits because it was
like
um
just not as sensitive as perhaps it
might have been
um and then disappeared but then once
shang chi did well they excavated it
from the archives
and put it back out for people to see
speaking of which shanghai
or sean chi if i remember correctly
um
continues to [ __ ]
do well
the biggest movie of the pandemic they
said
it is i mean it's it's
200 million dollars domestic i think
over that
it's performing like gangbusters and
continues to do so
and venom 2 opened at 90 million
which is the number two
uh october opening of all time
pandemic or no
is that right wait say that again so
they they did a record number in the
pandemic only the joker opened at a
higher weekend
they were not facing a pandemic they
were not facing a pandemic so
you know perhaps sony played their cards
right and and just held out
and said you know we're going to wait it
we're going to see
i think i'm thinking that then that
their let there be carnage was r-rated
because the uh there's there's a [ __ ] in
there
i don't know if it's one [ __ ] in my head
maybe it was more than one [ __ ] but
there's definitely a very prominent [ __ ]
in there not not a [ __ ] mark but
somebody
saying [ __ ] i'd tell you a couple venoms
[ __ ] in that movie because that'd be
odd but then again you might not know
what you saw i just saw [ __ ]
tentacles everywhere maybe they were
[ __ ] maybe not what do you think andy
circus is some sort of michael bay where
you can't tell who the [ __ ] is fighting
who in a transformers movie andy circus
is a [ __ ] filmmaker my friend
um he's gonna he's i mean look the dude
was already huge as [ __ ] gollum and
planet of the apes look at him as a
director now stop that not you open that
big guess where you are a-list my friend
absolutely seems like a nice guy in all
the interviews i've ever seen him in he
seems like real amiable and [ __ ]
i mean and i like that he just seems to
be a worker like he just wants to play
like you want me to be [ __ ] alfred
i'll be outfit you want me to direct
venom happy to do it want me to go and
be a voice for this thing you got it
what do you need i'm going to be claw
i'll be claw until the cows come home
tell you something i'll watch him
[ __ ] do claw forever man i thought he
was so [ __ ] fantastic i was spoilers
i was bummed
[ __ ] died in black panther
i have to say spoilers because somebody
[ __ ] [ __ ] me out and [ __ ] chat
they're like oh sure spoil kingsman and
i'm like i mean that movie's like
[ __ ] five years old i think at this
point almost 10.
um you know what i say
i say we all join the circus my friend
uh i hope he has enough room at his
house because let us let us under your
big top andy danny
um yeah
[ __ ] like now that he crushed it for
them and this made a bunch of money
you know they probably you watch he's
going to get a star war
he's going to get a dc
he's going to get another marvel
like a marvel marvel not a sony marvel
i bet you at some point when they decide
to reboot planet of the apes again like
he said dude you call and when they
[ __ ] do the 19th reboot of lord of
the rings
gollum directs it's
gonna happen good for him and he seems
again he seems like a really good guy i
watched one of those videos
where i forget which company does it
vanity fair or somebody or google maybe
it's google where they like
do this like search
and they say like you know oh yeah i'm
hardy what is tom hardy's age or
whatever like that and it was andy
circus and tom hardy and it was the one
during which tom hardy told the story
about the voice of bane
he did an impression of the guy the old
boxer that he kind of lifted the voice
from and he just
slipped into it
so effortlessly where he's like would i
have to ring with a bomb
you know it was just like i blew my
[ __ ] mind i was like that is so dope
and he talked about how with bane
like there was two directions to go the
character has latin orange or oranges
origins
though naturally you know he was born in
what the santa priska prison or
something like that if i remember
correctly i'm wrong about the name of
the prison but like you know you could
have went that way or he was like look i
don't look the part at all so what if i
went with this like weird [ __ ]
british boxer voice stuff it's such a
and he said like chris nolan was like
let's go with that
and
thank god he did man like that
that is like what will endlessly be
fascinating about that movie you know
like nolan made a wonderful flick but
falling like as you listen to tom hardy
speak in that movie just falling down
the rabbit hole of like
how does this get through
like
i love it but how did somebody high up
not be like are we sure we want to do
this it's like it's it ran the jack
sparrow gamut where it's just like this
shouldn't have [ __ ] happened somebody
in a higher position like normally
slap [ __ ] like this down but like a
really [ __ ] good bold idea got
through in a mainstream movie go figure
yeah it uh it reminds me a bit of like
benicio del toro in like every other
benicio del toro thing where it's just
what's he doing yeah what is this on
like purpose did did we all okay this
thing but it's great right i think it is
we'll see
did a whole movie where you like you
needed to put on the subtitles to
understand his what the [ __ ]
what's up for real
now did you see what the what if episode
where you know he was a character
in the
party thor episode yeah
and was it
benicio has been in two of them he was
in the t'challa's star-lord
as uh that's the same character as the
collector so he's done his own voice
yeah
that's awesome um did you watch uh you
watch party thor that was so [ __ ] fun
what was the one that just happened um
what if ultron won
oh that was [ __ ] wonderful and dark
they've all been [ __ ] great man like
when does this stop when are they when
does this end wednesday tomorrow is the
last episode of the season yeah
let me tell you something you point to a
better [ __ ] first season
like of of uh five other shows man like
my god it was [ __ ] in the last two
years i should really narrow that down
otherwise like sopranos i love lucy like
i get it
uh an amazing [ __ ] auspicious start i
i honestly feel like every episode was a
winner they didn't drop the ball
i would say i could do with them killing
less avengers all the time no way kill
more are you [ __ ] kidding me this is
the twilight zone let him kill all these
[ __ ] man they'll never do it in the
real movies so this is where we get to
like purge every character that we love
turn them into zombies cut them in half
and [ __ ] how wicked was that when
[ __ ] vision was like swamp and just
cut thanos in half and i'm like pick up
oh it was fantastic
yeah like i could do like once twice
maybe but like there was a run there of
like four episodes where all we're doing
is killing t'challa over and over again
and i'm like
which wasn't just t'challa it was a lot
of
a lot of people
all of them like how would we cry who's
gonna kill your adventures over and over
again um
they're still uh and wisely so i'm not
saying how dare they but like not
introducing any characters that aren't
in the cinematic universe am i correct
or am i
you know you count dark doctor strange
but i i don't that's just dr strange but
like they everything has been
from the movies and no characters who
are not in the movies have been at play
i don't believe so i mean i think that
other than like how the doctor cameo who
has a post-credit sequence seen in in
the first guardians and the watcher
um uatu is the only new character that
we haven't seen before fair enough
you're absolutely right yeah and [ __ ]
you know the narrator for god's sakes
and more than the narrator
now gets involved in the [ __ ] action
has he ever fought in the comics not
that i recall but i was like oh [ __ ]
dimensional warrior or watching she's
going for it i love the very simple but
elegant visual of them smashing through
dimensional barriers like they were
glass you know windows yeah like
one after another was really really dope
it's gorgeous
um so yeah i'm excited for tomorrow and
i think tomorrow it's
i think tomorrow's episode is as the
finale begins to pull at the threads of
things that didn't feel quite resolved
in season one
that's actually connecting all of the
stuff together um so i look forward i
look forward to that because that had
been my one bugaboo is that some of
these endings felt less like endings
anymore just like we ran out of story
in chat esther souter said tony stark
died in every episode he was in is that
the is that true
um
i think so
i think so i don't know if he doesn't
party for
but i don't remember if he's in party
for her i don't think he's in party
though is he
then again don't trust me i'm the
[ __ ] who thought [ __ ] let
there be carnage was our rated r
um
while we were on marvel and we have
alex in chat said kev is out for blood i
hope there isn't a what if ted lasso oh
let me tell you
dark nate returns
yeah again what's going on with nate man
can you believe they're going to end the
season this way he did him dir you know
what i'm gonna
don't spoil it i'm gonna spoil it but
yeah i've i've heard i've heard
criticisms of this show specifically on
the nate
shelly angle of
you know why
how could you do that to nate
and it's like well he was a puppy in
season one
and if you're looking to break an
audience's heart
then you do bad things to the puppy
and so
i mean if you're looking to get angry
letters from the viewers yes you do bad
things to a puppy
i i didn't i didn't bump into it as as
hard you know i bet you i thought for
the actor i'm sure the actor was like oh
[ __ ] this is dope man i just
play other colors and stuff and if you
know they have some sort of split
because you can't expect
you know
expect the unexpected when it comes to
[ __ ] ted lasso so right now it looks
like oh my god this is bleak but they
might
spin it and wrap it up in a nice way or
what looks like right now is
you know
splitsville going into the next season
and stuff yeah but um
yeah oh
but i'm buying it i i don't there's
nothing where i'm like oh man they
betrayed everything i loved about this
show i'm like no i'm
i'm in like some people
just [ __ ] you know go south on you
you know sometimes it ain't even you
it's obviously nate's got some issues
twice now we've seen him spit at himself
in a mirror very disturbing indeed
um but also if if ted lasso is a show
about anything it's a show about
forgiveness
and so it does not surprise me if even
if they split at the bottom of season
two if season three
is all about sort of closing that loop
and sort of bringing the team back
together uh in chat orion lieutent
said have you not seen john wick
bad thing to a puppy is a plot line
that's the reason why there's a job
um all right uh i guess uh there's
enough of our chit chat at the top
should we dive into the news i feel i
feel like we had been in the news for a
while so we might as well make it
official yeah kids we've been in the
news we didn't even [ __ ] tell you man
boof you're into cruising [ __ ] you
backdoored into the news kids yeah we
did
um what stories have you got
um well one of them was going to be
venom 2 opening to 99 but we hit that
already
let's do the rumor of the week
the rumor of the week which i first
encountered on saturday
is that marvel is currently prepping
daredevil season 4 for disney plus
now i too
have run across this rumor on the
internet yes
and then i saw another story that said
there's no source on this whatsoever and
and there's no noise from inside disney
plus about this
yeah
it's one of those things where like once
you start seeing a story like this pop
up
you know based on an exclusive from an
insider who knows something and put it
on his patreon
um
not that patreon isn't great not that
there aren't insiders and not that they
don't have exclusives but
if nobody else has been able to confirm
the story or picked up on this story if
you know not to say that big news is the
final orbiter of all things but if
variety or collider or slash film or
home reporter or deadline or ew or
any of these other sort of trusted news
outlets haven't even re-reported it yeah
i don't believe it um
and so it seems to have just as quickly
as it scratched the itch that lots of
people had to see charlie cox again
um back as as matt murdock um
it seems to have faded away
uh in chat
uh sinistar99 said i put my secret stash
book on my desk in front of the screen
and nobody is signing it what's going on
in reference to the fact that when we're
at the cantina
you're right in front of us and we could
sign it i thought that was a very cute
joke well um and i needed that cute joke
because like [ __ ] all this [ __ ] teasing
about daredevil season [ __ ] four man
like this is wishful thinking
i mean we don't get a little bit of
concrete proof i i don't know
i you know it's
it's it's it doesn't seem like it's a
real thing i wish it was real i hope it
is [ __ ] real man i loved that show it
was amazing
but
this seems like
people trying to will it into existence
no more so than an actual scoop
yeah i mean it's it's one of those
things where i do i do believe
that at some point
kevin feige will want to play with the
toys that are
you know daredevil and luke cage and
jessica jones
um
but i think that if it happens it
probably won't happen like this
that's all i gotta say
oh i thought you were gonna show us the
way you set it up you're like it'll
happen like this and i was like did you
prepare a little video or something
i'd like to turn your attention to my
powerpoint presentation mark has upped
his [ __ ] game
i gotta start doing some power points
can i share the screen is that okay
uh blaze melandra on uh in the in the
chat said i heard wilson fisk
is going to be in the hawkeye show i'd
heard that as well
um and also echo
uh
there's an echo series
yeah it's in development that'll spin
out of hawkeye and potentially be its
own thing and there's a possibility that
that will
seed
some of those characters from the
netflix marvel universe that's david
mack's character david and joe casada
created echo yeah
those guys must be like holy [ __ ] man
they're [ __ ] doing an echo show
like
thank god we created echo
we're gonna be echo rich man like our
we're gonna we're gonna be billionaires
echoing in the halls of [ __ ] where
did the rich people go you're gonna be
hanging out robert kirkman's [ __ ]
house
yeah meanwhile brubaker's like don't
count your money yet bro
yeah really
really we met a guy who's like it
doesn't really work like that yeah i
mean good luck
um what else we got mark um
speaking of marvel and money
before we could ever talk about marvel
and money i'm gonna have to take a drag
of one of these fine cbd smokes
please don't let me get in the way
now i'm ready for this news
um scarlett johansson and marvel have
come to terms over their lawsuit over
the black widow payday well that was
fast what's my cut
uh i believe you get nothing other than
potentially um black widow 2.
god damn it man well kids if you want to
help me out because i've been shut out
of the [ __ ] scar joe settlement
uh go to walmart and buy this booby
shirt there you go
of this and a jay and silent bop shirt
it's only 10 bucks
you know that way i'll never get that
scarjo money but you know maybe i get
some of that jeremy renner money
you have to buy yourself a nice burrito
from the wawa he had that app and that
app made [ __ ] ducats
sure he had an album that came out along
with his uh with an ad for jeep i
believe um cleaning up
take that runner money how much you
think scarjo walks away with
well she was paid uh 20 million dollars
for the movie
um up front
that was her deal but part of her
contract was that there was some
theatrical um a share of the theatrical
revenues
and her issue was that by releasing it
on disney premier at the same time as
theatrical
that then cut into the potential
for those theatrical revenues um the
amount of the settlement was undisclosed
although some people are
sort of eyeing a 40 million dollar
payout figure
for her in addition to her initial 20
million salary
so she did okay
20 million dollars to be in the movie
yes 40 million dollar bonus based on its
performance um she's she is i'm sure her
lawyers are saying if it had a
traditional theatrical release
that would have been her cut
of a even mid-range marvel movie
tends to make around 600 million dollars
and so her her kind of theatrical would
have been probably around there
um mark how do we star in a marvel movie
as quickly as possible
well i figure we need to identify the 50
year old uh
relatively out of shape male heroes
and then convince kevin feige to be like
hey bro
give us the willy lumpkin movie yeah
we'll introduce the fantastic four back
dorm in our [ __ ] movie
we uh we can be the uh the like out to
sea heroes for hire i'll be luke cage
you can be danny ray
uh xavier campon who i believe uh i
quoted before in chat says uh she
meaning scarjo can thank uh shang chi
is that you think that's accurate the
success of shang chi made them be like
oh let's pay out
um i think the success of shanxi was
proof positive that if they have
released it or held it for a little bit
um to a a slightly more post-covered um
or these post throws of the pandemic
world that it would have made
a vastly increased sum that it did when
it came out when it did
um so i don't think it's like look at
all this money we have we're going to
give her a chunk of it i think it's more
oh nice hella
we were talking marvel it only seemed
appropriate i know so you've been acting
today you can you can't turn off that
bug
it's true man it's true all the world's
a stage mark um i got to do lines too
not like
i mean
but not those kind of lines i got to do
dialogue and that's something i rarely
get to do oh what's that like
it sounds exactly like [ __ ]
it sounds like this
i got to play myself i don't know if i'm
allowed to say this yet
i was acting last week as well
in
a i don't let me you know what before i
[ __ ] say this let me just enter the
word and see if they even announce it
yes yes hold on
um yes uh in deadline october 23rd 2020
no [ __ ] that march 18th 2021
nickelodeon green lights warped a new
live-action buddy comedy series from
co-creators kevin coppalow and heath
seifert
um it is a a show set
in a comic book store
um
[ __ ] adorbs man and uh they asked me
to come be in it and stuff so i got to
again i don't know if i'm spoiling [ __ ]
but i got to like
i got here let me leave it at this i
went to the set of warped
and
having being a guy that owns a comic
book store that [ __ ] set was accurate
as [ __ ] but
very on point but i was sitting there
going like
man i told the creators i was like i'm
so mad i should have created this show
like why the [ __ ] didn't i think
to set a show in a comic book store i
love this [ __ ]
um so you always tell at least i always
tell the good ideas by the ones that i'm
like
that should have been me um
but uh
it was reality if only i'd written a
script
but um it it looks good the
episode i'm in is very funny
i'm uh yeah
again i hope i
don't i hope i didn't [ __ ] with
plans that they didn't get out of me
yeah i got a big [ __ ] mouth mark i've
helped me my whole life like shut the
[ __ ] up but i had a good time it was
such a fun [ __ ] thing to do yeah i
told them i was like i live so close
you could write me into every episode
and they were like ah and i was like no
i'm [ __ ] serious now probably after
this they're like you're never coming
back you're spoiling [ __ ]
oh it's kevin loose lips smith coming
back to the set again aren't you
is that you you know what that rolled
off your tongue a little too fast do
people call me kevin
[Laughter]
i almost stumbled over it i had to give
it a little bc flare
it's amazing how quickly i began to fall
into the speech patterns of british
columbia when i was up there for like
four days
in enough cabs and like hang out with
enough people and you just start doing
that thing where you're you're in the
middle of the orange just beginning to
like a roller coaster oh it's been a
great con eh yeah are you having a good
time up here
you know enough with the covet already
eh it's like let us go out and enjoy our
timbits and our
double doubles
have you been to shooters yet it's the
one strip club we have in town
because you get into different
conversations than i ever did
at
vancouver my friend instantly they
profile you and be like wanna go to a
strip club
you look like you want to put them on
the glass i got a place for you
is that what one does in a strip club
isn't putting it on the glass
what is that referred to
the the the uh as i remember it in the
olden booths right like yeah the 42nd
street like put a coin yeah yeah that's
putting it on the glass or
the guy in midnight express when oh
bailey that was
on the glass
oh man good memory you know it's a
[ __ ] show when we're quoting midnight
expressed
did not have that on the bingo card for
today
um so yes scarjo made her back she and
disney are now perfectly happy with each
other
and so she can go off and do more disney
movies as was probably always going to
happen but now they'll be less awkward
little scarlett
happy at last indeed
somewhere colin jost is just like
this jackpot never ends
i mean
like
am i going to find out the end of my
life that i'm angel heart how did i get
all this
oh colin you go write your little jokes
yeah
i mean can you imagine like every year
when [ __ ] snl renewal comes up he's
just like
go ahead [ __ ] fire me
yeah
what am i gonna do
yeah oh lauren
is this the pay raise you're gonna give
me
ask me if i care i'm only here because i
need a thing to do on weekends
gotta be 50 50 right oh yeah yeah yeah
for sure
calculating their net worth in my head
i don't know why
it's never thought i'm so not a money
person but suddenly i'm like she just
got 40 million dollars
yeah
where's she going to put it
that's a lot of [ __ ] dough honey you
gotta buy a bigger house to hold all the
money and you know he's got that [ __ ]
tom and jerry money he really does i
mean he is the richest man on staten
island
we in there brian quinn
true yeah now they can fight for it it's
true the king of staten island yeah
of the non-vampires kings of staten
island uh they are they are the two
um what else we got
um james gunn
is developing another project with dc
on the heels of suicide squad and
peacemaker what is it there's another
thing he's been being very circumspect
about it um i mean he's got guardians
three which if you if you've watched his
instagram at all you can see someone's
filmmaking process because he apparently
storyboards
every single shot of the movie which
most people do you know if you're
operating at that level where there's a
thousand departments that'll have to be
on the same page there's you know kind
of stupid visual effects and production
design and
you know autos and weapons and all
everybody needs to know what everybody
else is doing
it's a story about a movie but his
process is he has one sheet of paper one
like a little bit of cardstock
per storyboard and so sometimes his like
i did a sequence of action sequence and
he's got a stack of cards on his desk
that's like this high
um so he's hard to work on it he's he's
busy he's like yeah by the time i'm done
i will have a tower of of cards that
will represent the entire movie that we
can put up on a big wall and you can
walk into a room of a movie
because never see man that's why [ __ ]
i'll never be successful that [ __ ] never
occurred to me
like i'll just put the all the movie on
cards so you can see it before the movie
happens and stuff
never occurred to me once good idea
take a storyboard to the logical degree
whereas you storyboard the entire
[ __ ] movie yeah it's very animation
that way because that's also how they
they pitch animated movies even and not
by like oh right it was making anime
movie it's
there's a there's an ongoing pitch
process in a cartoon
where walk into this room and it's a
story session and you can see how every
sequence develops and you can begin to
adjust and move and
because once you animate it it's very
hard to change things um but
so uh he went to twitter and was doing a
sort of q a
and he said that uh he uh
his twitter exchange with a fan uh just
said yes i'm developing another dc
project
besides peacemaker
um
there's much speculation as to what that
could be um
it's entirely possible there could be
another suicide squad movie
similarly because dc and warner brothers
do not seem like they want to let that
franchise die
um
maybe
blaze melandra and chad said i'm real
curious as to what character james gunn
was referring to
when he said he's introducing one of
marvel's greatest characters
in the holiday special did you see this
you know he's doing the guardians of the
galaxy holiday special
and i guess he tweeted that they're
going to introduce uh or he did an
interview said they're going to
introduce one of marvel's greatest
characters in the holiday special
now naturally some people are like oh my
god it's nova oh my god it's
[ __ ] adam warlock oh my god it's blah
blah
but
blaise melandra says probably
santa
because sam they did do a marvel title
about santa santa is technically
part of the marvel universe he had his
own comic at one point so that's
adorable do you think he's doing a
little bit of having fun with this i
wouldn't go so far as to say bait and
switch i've been at the receiving end of
that mark and i don't even sign it
um i feel like like you know it's a bit
of a tease could be blaze is right that
it actually is
you know santa would you make a lot of
sense
that would be adorable and that would be
you know a debut in the marvel universe
for sure now he's an mcu canon
santa can deliver presents to all of
these disney's like and now we own santa
well done everybody yeah we've got them
all we have your entire childhood now
pretty much
um so yeah it's uh there may be more
information at the dc fan dome which i
really was in a couple of weeks
i saw a tweet with a thousand [ __ ]
names in it so many names i was like am
i in this no
not not at all the only smith i saw was
tiffany smith god bless you yes
indeed she stays busy she stays working
yelling always um
so yeah who knows what that is but i'm
i'm always curious to see what james
gunn is up to
it's always oh
maybe it's a polka dot man
show
i'd watch that [ __ ] just mulch him
that's important see to that character
yeah he was my favorite character in the
world
just because i got him i understood him
um what else we got dude captain kirk is
actually going to outer space
wow
and i found this kind of delightful yeah
90 years old william shatner is hopping
on jeff bezos's blue origin space flight
on october 12th and is going
where no man that old has gone before
there you go
i was gonna say a lot of [ __ ] men
they're poor
women as well but yeah no
man that old
has gone before it seems accurate it's
[ __ ] crazy though when you look at
him and you're like
that guy's 90 like he looks 70 max
so
but still 90.
you can help you know they ain't putting
them up in space if he's not in the peak
of health could you imagine if william
shatner
dies on jeff bezos's spaceship in outer
space
like
fingers crossed it doesn't happen i
don't wanna never die number one
horrible thought but but you know that
would be the end of amazon
you killed captain kirk with your
spaceship
[ __ ] you
um how awesome for him man
yeah ground control to to uh major uh
captain kirk captain kirk
you're trying to think
it really was
um wow man the shack
just chatting all over space
this is a trail space just taking a big
shot man
um well space is not ready for william
shatner no i mean earth barely is
yeah we were lucky to have him for as
long as we have now space is gonna meet
go captain my captain
i feel like if he doesn't while he's up
there for all of the 13 minutes that he
will be in orbit um
i just wanted to like recite lines from
star trek too
see i go the other way i want him to run
into extraterrestrial life who are not
fans of star trek but tj hooker instead
where they're like we've come for the
hooker
you don't have that in your plan he's
like the tj hooker slide across a hood
am i allowed to do the martian voice or
is that off limits as well i think you
can do martian i think it is not as much
trouble as italian
oh slaughter
speaking of italian how did we not talk
about i don't know if
were you a big sopranos fan uh i was but
it's been it's been you know 20 years
since i engaged in the sopranos you mean
you didn't re-watch the sopranos during
the uh pandemic like a lot of people did
i did not i was well i went i went for
another drive through [ __ ]
newark and the surrounding areas my
friend the oranges
and the oranges absolutely it was so
[ __ ] wonderful so i was delighted to
watch uh the many saints of newark which
premiered you know in theaters and of
course on hbo max
last weekend and uh you know [ __ ]
like
how do you talk about it without
spoiling it
well i know that tony sopranos may or
may not have been shot in a diner so
um
i know where it where it goes they they
that that diner makes an appearance
like in the movie like the place where
tony and died in the show you know
because it's young tony
so all the same places existed in newark
so yeah they go back to i think it's
called halston snow
holton's
um
good flick though yeah you know you know
definitely informed by my love of
the sopranos so there were cool easter
egg moments of like oh oh oh oh oh
but you know compelling enough story in
its own right you know touched on the
newark riots pretty
heavily as a key turning point in the
movie and stuff like that so you know
it was
i you know i i love the [ __ ] out of it
watching it at home
um but i would have wanted to see this
in the movie theaters i thought uh like
james gandolfini's kid did a really nice
job it's very point very sweet to see
him play
his father vera farmiga was excellent
you know as the young version of olivia
um i wish the lord would take me
she's that that she's i love that show
because that woman sounded like my
grandmother
my grandmother was not like a
narcissistic psychopathic sociopathic
like hate tank like livia but
she would say the same [ __ ] [ __ ] like
ah go on and [ __ ] and i wish the lord
would take me i don't know what happened
to all those people who [ __ ] lived in
newark man but it's in the blood they
just want the lord to take them
just defeated by things
i hope i never get to that point in life
where i'm like oh mark i just want the
lord to take me i mean number one that
would be me going like hey i'm back on
that lord thing
circle back i mean ironically i'm really
sad that i made dogma
but
but uh i hope that i'm just like you
know my grandmother lost her sight so
she would say that a lot so she was like
blind for a good 10 years and so you
know she couldn't even do the things she
liked doing like crocheting and making
[ __ ] you know dumplings and stuff
like that
so you know i i get it she's kind of
trapped in darkness and [ __ ] her
husband was dead all the people she knew
were [ __ ] dead and like her kids were
all grown up had lives of their own and
some of them were dead sheep some kids
beat her into the grave
so i get it you know it was never a
pleasant thing to hear when he goes hey
graham how you doing well he i prayed
and he just won't take me like who's
that graham she's like jesus and you're
like oh man
really pray that jesus will take it
graham and she's like yeah i don't i
don't need to be here anymore but
every night i pray and he doesn't take
where do you go with a conversation from
there i i brought these muffins
you're like so you want to play some
rummy gram
i can't see the cards well i'll tell you
what they are that was good that was
what we did we'd always play cards
together and [ __ ] and then when she
couldn't see cards went out the window
as well
um long days sitting in the darkness and
long days you know for me to visit her
but my god how long those days must have
been for her so you know what maybe she
could be forgiven for being like i wish
the lord would take me
but uh she made it to 88.
welcome to
beyond the grave park heaven where we
talk about dead relatives that you've
never met and have no effect on your pop
culture enthusiasm batman beyond the
nail
[Laughter]
my grandmother would have been mystified
by all this [ __ ] oh yeah i mean i've
told you about my grandfather before who
did not believe in the moon landing were
dinosaurs and so
podcasting would have been like what the
are you just talking to people he's like
look i didn't believe in the moon
landing or dinosaurs that's what i said
but what i meant was i believe that
dinosaurs landed on them
cooler let's run with this like [ __ ]
your boring history mine's got dinosaurs
[Laughter]
let there be carnage on the moon
somewhere steven spielberg is like
that's kind of like e.t crossed with
jurassic park let's [ __ ] do it
just do it
let's do jurassic off world [ __ ] it
let's go
yes
jurassic 10 jason goes to space
uh what else we got speaking of italians
there is a rocky ford director's cut
that is coming to theaters on november
11th
apparently sylvester stallone
has added 40 minutes of
never-before-seen footage
to the 1985 movie
40-4-0-4-0
i i hope there's more of that robot
footage
according to the trailer yeah
happy birthday paulie i could watch 10
more minutes of that [ __ ]
that was four right that wasn't three
that was four that was four
um that's right they're like we're going
to russia kid here's a [ __ ] robot you
could [ __ ]
your robot babysitter
make me and your mother and your [ __ ]
drunk uncle goodbye moscow
um
yeah does this family go he's like do
you think
they're coming back and he's just like i
am now in charge
that's why i remember rocky five his kid
hated him that's why yes maybe that's
the connective tissue we're getting it's
why milo intermediate hates
[ __ ] rockefeller like that [ __ ]
robot threw me a beat
every day
that robot touched me dad in places no
robot should touch you i've been probed
you took a dark very very good clearly
it was going there
i was i was trying to surf
you know the the tasteful wave you took
us right into the depths my friend yeah
you were in the pg-13 and i went
straight r
i went better go r because [ __ ]
carnage didn't and look what happened to
that movie they didn't make any money
whatsoever if i had to guess this will
be an unrated film
that will not be so because of content
but because they probably won't
represent it to the mpaa for a rating
given that they're adding new [ __ ] to it
huh i mean i don't know if you can do
that i think you have to represent to
the mbaa
it
depends at the very least i know that
when director's cuts would go on video
it would be like the actual cut is the
rating and then unrated is whatever the
the content the new content would be
um
so yeah man i i listen
i love me some rocky
i love me some rocky four
not as much as i like rocky iii but
rocky iv
made 300 million dollars worldwide back
in 1985 when that was real [ __ ] money
yeah no doubt um it appeared to it
appealed to everybody it was like usa
usa
[ __ ] and even [ __ ] the russians in
that movie [ __ ] come to rocky's side
eventually like rookie
rocky
did you ever see that fake um you know
espn has a 30 for 30 documentary series
they made a fake one about how actually
this fight brought about glasnost and
and the fall of the
berlin wall and it's cute it's so great
um
but yeah so 40 more minutes stallone
will have a live q a in select markets
um in partnership with fathom
and mgm who are putting this out
if i get more rocky give it to me didn't
know that i wanted it but now you're
telling me i can get it give it to me i
i yeah honestly i didn't care but when
you said 40 i'm like that's what the
[ __ ] what does that look like i want to
see what 40 more minutes of rocky iv
looks like
oh look man is here everybody do you
think they spent more or less money than
the snyder cut spent on the extra 40
minutes of that
way [ __ ] less are you kidding me oh
my god mgm was like look if you want to
do this you pay for it it's like
stallone with a razor blade and some
tape in her editing room is a [ __ ]
filmmaker this guy is not just a academy
award-winning screenwriter but he's a
very accomplished director i would not
be surprised if he kept all of his
[ __ ] trims in order and stuff like
that
and waited for the right time this guy
is one of the original brilliant
self-marketers and certainly understands
how to extend his [ __ ] career man i
mean he's got a hundred million dollar
grocer in every decade of the last what
four decades so i wouldn't be surprised
if a young stallone was just like no
this will have a home one day and you
know it's never been on dvd before or
anything like that no it has it has but
not these 40 minutes these 40 minutes
have never been seen that's what i'm
saying the 40 minutes have never even
been a yeah wow i mean that's that's a
long con hold on to it that long to not
like you know [ __ ] succumb to
laserdisc
or dvd before he's finally like no i'm
holding out because one day this world's
gonna [ __ ] fall to a germ
and then they're gonna want their past
and that's when i'm going to stick in
the extra 40 minutes
extra 40. all robot action
the robot comes out to fight he's like
happy birthday paulie and he fights
but he is some kind of button
you want me
i am look i like the rocky saga i love
saga listen to me saga i liked it when i
was a kid but like i love
the creed direction of it i love that
they kept the [ __ ] going where i'm like
holy [ __ ] i had no idea how much i
missed this mythology
but uh i'll wait until this extended cut
comes to a home video i'm not rushing
out to see that no you're not gonna head
to the theater for uh for for rocky 4
plus 40.
no i mean i honestly don't even know if
i'd rush for rocky 3 plus 30.
you know
and i like that one way more than four
but still
now you tell me creed with an extra 50.
give you my money [ __ ] take it yeah
particularly if it's a lot of like kids
popping wheelies in the street
really captured my imagination never
mind
fighting stuff i've seen many movies
with fighters but
give me more atvs popping wheelies
um what else we got going on that is all
the news my friend
are you [ __ ] me i am not at all uh
banff man did you pop in to say
something
oh yeah i muted my mic i said i got a
couple things but i was a real stealth
band that was like one sneak banff man
yeah i got a couple things we can chat
about real quick okay
um
they announced
man ladies and gentlemen jc the
proprietor
of scum and villainy cantina right there
in hollywood on hollywood boulevard
which is open right now for your
drinking pleasure and eating pleasure
they serve food i saw food go by the
other day yeah tater tots yeah that's
the specialty
um
they uh they announced when you can book
your voyage on the disney galactic star
cruiser
so if you're a club 33 member
you can call up and book
to go to the star wars hotel that's
completely immersive
so all the windows in the hotel are like
hd tv screens that look out onto space
so
there's a rollout that started today for
like vips and people but on october 28th
people like me can go on and uh shuffle
all my life savings
to walt disney for two nights
on uh the galactic star cruiser so
anybody who's looking forward to that
are you doing it are you gonna do it
jason i am going to do it of course he's
good yeah i mean i really want to it's
so funny because everyone's like they
got no windows i'm like yeah like a
[ __ ] casino yeah
yeah
you're going to be in a thing and you're
in an adventure the whole [ __ ] time
so when you look out your window you see
[ __ ] space and tie fighters floating
around how dope is that how much is it
um
the sample pricing they put out so if
you want to squeeze four adults into a
tiny tiny little room
it's 700 around 750 dollars per adult
per night
if you just want two adults it's like
1500
per adult per night
and those are prices in the fine print
for
starting in august of
2022.
so
the hotel opens in march
so if you want to go in the first six
months that the hotel is open
i think it's more expensive
and then the prices just go up from
there
wait it's more expensive and then the
prices go it's more sorry it's more
expensive for the first six months than
it is
starting in august of 2022. so if you
want to be one of the first people on it
you're gonna go for it yeah
um
yeah i honestly like that might be a
thing worth [ __ ] doing because
essentially
think about it your
how many nights is it
two nights so you arrive at like 1pm
and then you do stuff that day you sleep
you do stuff the whole next day you
sleep you get breakfast and they
shoot you out in an escape pod
i mean think about it
think about it it's like
you're paying for you know
premium
prices to stay at a really nice new
hotel
and you're also paying for broadway
tickets that's what it's like because
you're seeing a live show
for two days straight
i was i saw it not believe me i'm not so
far gone in this world that i'm like
it's reasonable
um it's not clearly
it's a very unreasonable price and it's
meant for people who have you know
unreasonable expectations of having a
good time at disney world and disneyland
so
i'm all for it but i also understand if
a bunch of people are like this is one
of the grossest elitist things i've ever
[ __ ] heard in my life or something i
get that too but think about
what you're actually paying for it is a
two day long
live-action performance of a star wars
movie it is in the midst of it's
once-in-a-lifetime kind of thing this
ain't like disney world where and i
ain't trying to sell it i got no skin in
this [ __ ] game but disney world you
can go visit and do it in a day maybe
two and then [ __ ] you know you can go
back in a couple years and do it again
or if you're a real disney freak you go
every [ __ ] week and [ __ ]
this sounds like something you'll do
once
and then never [ __ ] again in this
lifetime
i and the itin like the sample itinerary
you can you have like a sabacc game that
you can sit down and play
you uh the one of the like casinos you
go to they have like live cantina band
music
so you can like watch
some galactic band play galactic music
it's
yeah it just i know it how ridiculous it
is but it's like the only thing i've
ever wanted since i was five years old
you know
when does it go on sale uh so if you're
a member of club 33
are you
i am not
i don't love
the disney
disney stuff i'm i'm like the star wars
guy so um
apparently club 33 members could start
booking today
and then there's like a vip thing and
then if you have a visa credit card but
october 28th is the day that
that anybody can call and they're not
doing online you have to call on the
telephone to reserve
um like baby does the baby get to go for
free
i think so
that that'll be the that'll be the if i
have to pay for my 14 month old daughter
to go then i don't i don't know if we're
gonna drop the change on her
you're like this kid can't go so we're
gonna drop her off on a desert planet
tattoo
yes lars owen lars and his wife beru
we've got a shitty robot here who can
watch your kids work fine for the
stallone family
um you know what man like that you you
of all people deserve
to go there you deeply deeply
uh love this [ __ ] so this is my
uh gift to you
i will pay for your
disney star wars photo oh man
be careful what you promise on the
internet where people can see it i'm
saying jc everybody not [ __ ] anybody
else
oh thank you yeah you heard me ask if
the baby was free and you said yeah
[ __ ] baby i'll pay for some adults
because a baby be like it'd be wasted on
a baby yeah yeah yeah most people you
and your lady will absolutely enjoy it
you've done much for me over the years
the least i could do to send you there
so i know you're going regardless but
you book it i'll [ __ ] pay myself oh
thank you
and then you come back on the show and
tell us all about it uh yeah i'll shoot
video
yeah are you look what i stole are you
allowed to shoot [ __ ] video i mean
i'm sure you're not i
really i mean no way they charge you
that much money and they're like put
that [ __ ] phone
starter carrying you off
you can't shoot hamilton footage from
the [ __ ] seats even though you spend
a thousand dollars for those tickets
that's a good point that's right that's
true proprietary i also before your
[ __ ] phone away man that might that'd
be crazy before our show starts i'm
always like don't shoot video of fat man
beyond in the cantina
so if i'm saying that i'm sure disney's
like don't do this
you're walking around the [ __ ] ship
they're like what are you [ __ ] nuts
but somebody's gonna man they always
[ __ ] somebody always makes v you go
to youtube you could watch videos of
every [ __ ] dark ride in disneyland
disney world and [ __ ] universal and
stuff there's no way somebody ain't
gonna [ __ ] sneak a camera in there
man yeah they totally will but they
won't be happy about it yeah
oh yeah
no they're going to be like this
what
yeah
the the other thing that happened since
last show was um which
isn't as fun as all the rest of the
stuff but it kind of is um and it
affects everything we're talking about
is ayatsi
voted to authorize
uh
a strike in its negotiations so they
voted
90
of
union members voted and 96
of the people who voted voted yes
wow so
uh
if
the
studios don't play ball it looks like
we're going to lose
anything that has not been shot
uh
up until you know
october november
um
it does not affect clerks three though i
thought it was one right yeah well it
would affect us though
union members yeah we we wouldn't be
allowed to work on it
um the sound mixers and all of those
people wouldn't be able to do it but
because it's on a different contract it
doesn't affect our movie so we win um
but uh supportive of the strike and
still work through the show and still
work yeah
you win
i mean it seems hypocritical but yay for
me
yeah
you know it has something to do with the
low budget agreement we've would tear
under
yeah i mean
the iot fight as i understand it is
about hey enough with this new media
[ __ ] like
netflix is [ __ ] netflix pay us right
that's what it is correct i said so fat
and it's
we would like to have weekends we would
like to have meal breaks we would like
to
you know there should be a certain set
number of hours i get to sleep
you know it's so much of it feels like
it's just basic human decency that has
gone by the wayside as the studios just
try to get more content for less money
given everything you got nothing without
a [ __ ] crew you're only as good as
the people that are willing to help you
make your dream come true and don't
[ __ ] be like yeah they get [ __ ]
paid hey man there's a lot of jobs they
could be doing a lot of different things
getting shot they picked yours to work
on oh [ __ ] man i love
the [ __ ] crew so i support the
[ __ ] strike wholeheartedly man it's
also
it's also like on some of these new
media deals that are like netflix shows
you know the lead costume person or the
lead hair and makeups making like 17
bucks an hour
which is like
less these are all predicated on these
old deals on what
new media was [ __ ] 10 15 years ago
and it has changed obviously very
[ __ ] rapidly it's the dominant
[ __ ] media and yet they're not paying
aggregate prices to like film and
television so
right now everyone you know who works
under new media deals the studio side
the the people that make the content
you know
they don't have to shell out as much
money as a tv a network or a [ __ ]
movie studio based on
old contracts going you know forward
with with the unions and stuff so yeah
it's high time
like
to to renegotiate especially in a world
where it's like you know new media is no
longer experimental like it's netflix
it's apple it's amazon it's [ __ ]
disney like these are companies that
have a lot of money it's not like
they're hurting and can't afford to pay
going rates you know people what they
normally get when they work in film and
tv well and you you start to do the math
and like netflix has over a hundred
million six subscribers disney has over
a hundred dollars
200 million
and everybody's paying 10 bucks a month
so the math on that is they're making 20
billion dollars a month
every month on subscriber revenue
right
and it's like the what
do that map again so if it's i'm gonna
bust out my phone so i don't sound like
an idiot on the internet but if you have
200
million
people each month who are paying 10
bucks
i get two air 9.
is it 2 billion or 20 billion 2 billion
okay so it's 2 billion but that's still
24
billion dollars per year
on these streaming channels
and so
you know
you you can give people enough time to
get home and go to sleep
chickenmonkey33 and chat said what was
mark gonna say about his short
my short also falls under the uh the
super low budget
um
clause contracts whereas we are
we are then able to shoot even if the
iot goes on strike
you know and i similarly and i'm 100 in
support of it because
nothing ever changes unless you threaten
to take
the the food out of the corporate mouth
right like when the writers
you know the writers have not struck a
lot the writers guild but they struck
once and shut down hollywood for like 14
months
um
and then eventually you know the studios
came to terms and they realized that
okay yeah we turns out we cannot not
have the content we have i mean you can
thank that strike for things like
survivor
in big brother and reality tv as we know
it all of which were done quote unquote
without writers but
if i actually goes on strike which
they've never done in 150 some odd year
history
of of the
whatever it is the the international
association of television
something
employees
television stage employees
um
a theatrical stage in place um if they
go on strike everything stops
like almost everything stops every tv
show that you really love stops every
movie that you can't wait to go see
stops everything just takes a break
does the news stop
um
i believe it does i think they also like
cruz all i antsy there and stuff i think
some live network programming stuff
i mean i'm sure they will find a way to
automate it which you know they might
have done but where they're just
skeleton crew and the [ __ ] on the
news look like batman
like nobody can use any hair products
because the smilex poison so they're
like looking like hell yeah be off of
that
you know
many of the things that you love will
will not be coming to you in the at the
rate you expected to
and so
you know it always requires labor
to remind
management that they're essential to the
process yeah
and look as a guy who just finished
making a movie
what was i gonna do by myself with the
actors i'm not a [ __ ] run a thing i
don't know how to make anything work i'm
[ __ ] useless on a movie set unless
i'm surrounded by iatsy so
more power to them um in chat
we'll walk lightly here the open floor
said i don't mean to open up old wounds
lol
but i rather did enjoy
masters of the universe truly
when will the back half be released or
will it be released
um it'll definitely be released and uh
there's news of that coming very soon
nice
um wait wait a dodge
thank you now on to something else
before
somehow i get in trouble yeah um well
i'm out of news um jc is going to a
fancy star wars hotel
um
give it up
give it up for mark he gave you the news
give it up for jc he's getting what he
[ __ ] deserves and you know
usually when that happens in life it's a
bad thing
here it's a [ __ ] good thing
and uh you know give it up for me
because i'm i'm a published author yet
again
welcome that's secret steps look at look
at that
thick as a dick and when i say that
clearly i'm talking about my own dick i
know there are many people out there
like my dick is way thicker than that
well congratulations
i know a woman named schwab who's been
telling me you exist my whole [ __ ]
marriage
thicker dicks out there kevin i'm like i
know
i was in the locker room once
it's just weird when she says it in
front of my mother hey batman is here
what uh what you hanging about for i
just i figured i'd hang out until q a
because i figured that's who we were
going
did you pick questions i have some
questions
ladies and gentlemen
uh jc the proprietor
of uh scum and villainy cantina i'm like
i'm like brad dorf in the old dune i'm
like go quickly and quietly don't alert
anybody don't make a sound
without
uh me and mark have been talking about
finally doing our dune commentary i know
i feel like if it's going to happen
before the new dune comes out and which
were like you know just a
fremen hair away from it happening
what studio released the original dune
universal yeah
i wonder if i could i wonder if i could
screen it
at scum and villainy and we could do
do it live i'll have to check it with my
he could i'd be like i ain't fighting it
but it won't be as funny
it just it doesn't work that way
what i would probably do if we're going
to watch it is like what we've done on
the other flicks i would watch it the
night before take a bunch of [ __ ]
notes and then watch it again with mark
so that i had a bunch of notes at the
ready and swing sing
i'm like hella with those [ __ ] echo
knives
and i'm like
just like that nice
otherwise like a like a like a walrus
being born just yes
hello
look at you
walrus with the upside down [ __ ]
tusks man that's like a children's book
that hasn't been written yet holy [ __ ]
copyright trademark kevin [ __ ] ball
right here
the upside down tasks tusk swallows with
the upside down
he's always so happy like a [ __ ]
rudolph thing man like you know he's all
[ __ ] up until they need him and then
hey he opened the beer and then he
becomes a hero and [ __ ]
somebody was coming to attack the wall
you know this takes it very dark but
somebody's coming to attack the walrus
pack but he
you know they pushed him forward and
since his tusks were faced up they gored
the [ __ ]
and then everybody was like no and they
left walrus island and they're like oh
my god [ __ ] tusky
saved us we always teased him because
his [ __ ] was busted but
[ __ ] he literally gored and then they
were like you know tuskegee got the
taste for blood and he's like i hunt man
and so he goes into the water chases the
boat down knocks them into the water
feasts on men brings carcasses back to
walrus island and not only do they
[ __ ] like you know he's their best
friend now he's their [ __ ] king
because
i like how suddenly you've roped me into
tusk 2.
you need help man [ __ ] misery loves
company i ain't going through that [ __ ]
alone again first it was let's do a kids
book you know about the [ __ ] smiley
walrus he suddenly gets murdered husky
that's my problem man like everything i
don't want to take everything into a
dark area i should really just seize the
commercial
like instinct to just make it happy make
it a pixar movie but instead i'm like
and then the devil shows up
it's like oh it's the little walrus with
the upside down dust who can help like
all of the norse gods open their beer
like that's cute but no
no dragging bodies i like it where he
accidentally kills somebody and [ __ ] but
then
he gets a taste for it so he's like ah
like you know he's [ __ ] seen
man come to walrus island and take what
they've wanted for years now here's this
[ __ ] chance to fight back we will
have man flesh
i think i like it more as a revenge
thriller
clearly
clearly but there's more money in the
kid's story you know
the only way to go it seems as if to do
the uh
the kids story for adults
the the the walrus version of go the
[ __ ] to sleep did you ever see that the
sam jackson
yeah so just go the [ __ ] to sleep
i guarantee you kids would be [ __ ]
fat you know kids are weird right
they're always like into the weird [ __ ]
they would be fascinated by a story of a
walrus who was born with his tusks
upside down and [ __ ] like i had a kid
they their minds get captured their
imaginations get captured by the
weirdest stupidest [ __ ] detail and
that seems like one of those details
where people like come on man [ __ ]
this deer's got a red nose and for
generations we've been like what and it
glows like
people are [ __ ] simple like that so i
think if you did a walrus with his tusks
you know upside down
there's you know there's a lot of like
hey that's me a lot of people see
themselves in that walrus i mean it's
[ __ ] it's happy feet man like for
sure
i know it's i guess we didn't really
meant to new formula this has been done
rudolph happy [ __ ] feet
um i don't know all i'm saying is
there's money there's money in these
trees unless you turn them into i like
man flesh
then i feel like there's less money
that's where i go off the rails right
there yeah but people remember that i
like man flesh a lot more
you know there's a very small segment of
the population that loves it
loves it to death
like nine guys in norway we're just
gonna love this
michael hatch and chat says from tusk
till fawn
till fawn that's awesome um
gallant
in chat said tusk ii the murder blood
inning
not for nothing it's a great [ __ ]
title the murder blood
it's pretty good it reminds me of shit's
creek the the croning
the croning is that what they call it
yeah there's a whole birds like [ __ ]
thing where it was about a bunch of
murderous crows it was called like crow
to the croning
we're sitting there going hey this is
rudolph trevor golding very rightfully
pointed out the ugly knuckling like this
[ __ ] goes way far back isn't that
enhanced christian anderson [ __ ]
story pretty much yeah so our [ __ ]
upside down tusk walrus story totally
bites off hans christian anderson so
much so
that we'll name the [ __ ] walrus hans
and then it's homage and nobody says we
stole it
nobody would say it anyway and now we're
telling them we're stealing
oh god damn it we've revealed our
[ __ ] plan i gotta stop reading chat
um
chet wants to fail
listen to ryan b [ __ ] johnny come
lately did they talk about venom two yet
come on dude
come on just for two hours
[ __ ] hours ago we talked about that
[ __ ]
um all right
let's uh oh uh here's a question for me
eric peter carlson says any news on the
doc clerk yes go to csmod.com you can
get tickets i'm coming around for a tour
with the movie with malcolm we're going
to go out and bring the show on the road
we're going to austin we're going to uh
vancouver
st louis [ __ ] where else are we going if
you go to ceasemod.com you can see it's
like a mini tour of four or five dates
um we watch the movie and then we come
out and chit chat about it afterwards
and it happens in november so if you're
interested in seeing clark the
documentary about uh my life it's coming
very soon and for those of you who are
like but i'm not near any of those
[ __ ] cities what do i do
it's it'll be streaming all over your
face neck and chest new media as they
call it
anyway uh all right [ __ ] enough about
me
let's get to the murder blooding of it
all shall we
uh jc
pick a question for us all right uh
nadine lee morris uh was interested to
know if you could take any hannah
barbera ip
and turn it into a feature film what
would it be
and what would the storyline be
if i could take any hanna-barbera
property
and turn it into a feature film
a lot like uh spielberg did with the
flintstones
yeah flintstones or uh
is it yogi bear had some probably more
recent example
uh okay
i think
i mean like you know
the no-brainer would be the jetsons
because who don't [ __ ] love
the jetsons flying cars [ __ ] dog
walking
you know ramps and [ __ ] like that you
know jackson a mean ass boss we could
all identify with this
um
you know but that takes like
[ __ ] vision and green screen and time
and i don't know if i got the patience
for that so let me think
i might want to i mean there's a part of
me that wants to do hong kong phooey but
i bet you that's probably a little
difficult
you know i'm probably i'm probably not
the guy for it
in so many ways yeah yeah but yes
um i don't check any of the boxes what's
up
can't do the voice uh so many things
uh how about this
i don't know
magilla gorilla always fascinated me
because like that [ __ ] gorilla was
cheap and he still couldn't sell it like
who didn't want to pay five cents for a
gorilla
and how the [ __ ] didn't og have five she
couldn't scrounge together a [ __ ]
nickel cute kid like that just go up to
a relative and be like i want to buy a
gorilla for five cents so here you go
kid that's funny and she she literally
would have come home with a gorilla and
a hat and suspenders
and then everybody listens to you at
that point mark
nobody ignores little baby og after then
again you got a gorilla you you can set
the tone
oh yeah um all right so there's that's a
possibility but
you know
i wish i had been a bigger johnny quest
fan because that lends itself to live
action but i'm not into johnny quest um
let me see
what is my favorite oh oh [ __ ]
dangling in front of my face and i don't
see it i love superhero [ __ ]
i love [ __ ] dogs
you give me blue falcon and dino mutt
i'm a happy camper oh that's good
thank you thank you took a minute to get
there i had to surf through the
cobwebs of my mind mark but i eventually
arrived on something that i would be
very excited to do live action
blue falcon [ __ ] dynamite no
crossover i'm [ __ ] sticking any of
the scooby gang in as guest stars or
anything you save that [ __ ] for the
sequel if at all
because this is a concept that could
stand on its own a hero and his [ __ ]
heroic dog who's also a robot
what kid ain't gonna love that you know
it's like [ __ ]
it's like batman and jar jar
kid would love that yes
how about you what would you do uh i
mean you you hit it on the head in your
sort of island of castaway ideas johnny
quest i knew it
you'd be great for johnny quest man
cause you got that kind of adventure
episodic mindset man you'd like to build
set pieces and stuff yeah johnny quest
would be fun you get mike pence to play
that one guy
race banner yeah
you
he would never do it because it's steve
martin steve martin as race band and
kind of works as well i mean you need to
like put him through the marvel diager a
bit because like steve martin looks good
but he's also like 75 years old mark
what do you call people who are big fans
of race
um uh racially motivated
[Laughter]
do you like johnny quest yeah i'm a
straight-up racist what hold on
i mean i love race manning i i have i've
been working on this theory for a while
i like to call it my critical race
theory it's that race
jeff's kiss oh my god so timely
aging saturday live there's a guy who
could write for you
race banner and dr benjamin quest were
lovers really a short theory it's my
critical race theory on the show
like here's my critical race theory
why did that why do those two old men
hang out with those little boys so much
it seemed like good parenting i'm just
yeah like aren't they always putting
them in danger just by being around them
i'm very critical of this race
theory
but he could be a better father
they both
um
all right there you go two answers right
there two five answers i'll throw you a
third
okay i would do wacky races but i would
do it in the style of fast and the
furious
because it means you could get nine
ridiculous fun crazy movies out of it
and
people building those cars in the real
world like [ __ ] looking at cars that you
can see in a [ __ ] store window you
show me [ __ ] dick dastardly's car man
mutly's car and [ __ ] like that oh
penelope pit stops car build those
things in real life that's visually fine
now i
you know snaggle puss is has like a
bromance with
motley and
all the relationships you could have
dogs and cats living together mass
hysteria
i think you're confusing
the
wacky races for the laugh olympics
because these wacky races if i remember
correctly had a very set
cast of racers didn't include like hey
it's scooby-doo and [ __ ] laugh olympics
was the big end game crossover where
anybody could [ __ ] meet and play in a
sport maybe i'm wrong anybody in chat
want to back that up but i thought the
wacky races had a very specific cast
that was
insular to that show itself
i'm thinking like i remember watching it
had i thought it had like
motley and snaggle puss i because i'm
thinking of the one i was watching when
i was like mid 80s early 80s
jay kelly in chat says you are
definitely conflating the two i am
correct they said
uh
ash fox though is saying wacky races had
captain caveman so i don't know they
didn't i don't think wacky races did
have captain caveman
was there
getting into a serious conversation
about this but this is my childhood
we're talking about i remember the wacky
races as being dick dastardly penelope
pit stop
you know [ __ ] mutley was with dick
dastardly but it wasn't like the entire
breath of the hanna-barbera universe
whereas laugh olympics was
[ __ ] grape ape is fight squiddly
[ __ ] diddly like holy [ __ ]
maybe so
did i screw that up i may have screwed
that up i mean i was three so
i'm pulling out a long time ago
nightshade holloway says hanna-barbera
produced the show wait till your father
gets home i want an update it's true
they made like an animated sitcom it was
kind of like proto simpsons not nearly
as funny or biting but
it was called wait till your father gets
wait till your father gets wait till
your father gets home only one season
around but prime time animation if i
remember correctly um i'm i was looking
through the wikipedia of hannah barbera
productions and i see
partridge family 2200 a.d
and now i want to do that show i wanna
do the [ __ ] like the family that's
gotta sing songs to save the universe
in the future
uh yes
they had a dream they'd go traveling
together mark
just put a little love and they can keep
moving on something always happens
whenever they're together
now i'm mixing up all lyrics i love
there's two versions of the partridge
family song and one tells the secret
origin of the partridge family
like one is just general a lot you know
the song of course is come on get happy
and so one is just general like singing
will make you happy and [ __ ] but there's
one version of the [ __ ] partridge
family song that literally does their
secret origin which i think it was like
five of us and mom work and all day
uh
we knew
we could help her if our
music was good
danny no they go danny meaning you know
danny [ __ ] partridge
danny
told ruben meaning reuben kincaid their
agent to play our song and it sounded
even better when mom came along that's
the [ __ ] secret origin like their
their mom is like i got all these
[ __ ] kids and i'm working all the
time and they were like if we could just
[ __ ] put a band together a song
together and they did and then danny
partridge took it to [ __ ] reuben
cracked wise reuben played it and he's
like i think there's something here bam
you got the partridge fan
did they explain what happened to dad
they never did that's what we do in our
partridge family movie
it's [ __ ] we finally tell the story
of what happened to daddy partridge and
in our version the partridges get huge
and that's when he comes out of the
woodwork man
oh i was gonna go like six feet under
that like dad is dead and the ghost is
just it's a dark show with really dark
songs but it's
it's darker if he's alive and then he
comes to be a parasite you know what i'm
saying like they thought he was dead but
he was just like i you know i [ __ ] i
didn't want no kids and then all of a
sudden the kids got famous and he's like
it's my boy danny and [ __ ] david and
and susan and the other two whatever
but the worst is that then like mom had
lied to all the kids and said that he
died in like a motorcycle accident as a
cool writer or
worse worse
she put out a cover story because she
[ __ ] tried to kill him and she
thought she killed him because you know
he was a [ __ ] what a louse but he
[ __ ] played it very the long con
and waited to strike and now his
vengeance is high is nigh man it was
dark nobody even asked about the
partridge family
well i brought it up because departure
found me 22 20 22 a.d or whatever it was
a real show that was a cartoon it was a
cartoon them in the future because of
course they did that but now i want to
see this dark [ __ ] cartridge family
um we did fall down the [ __ ]
partridge hole
yeah we did
uh did we answer the questions
what's their
question did we just start talking yeah
though this that spun out of
hanna-barbera we're still trapped in the
first question
we are banff man get us out of here save
us bam
okay uh question number two is from
russell cook hold on
an update from gallant
partridge family two daddy's murder
blooding
uh okay uh russell cook
what would you title the james bond
movie starring yourself
hold that thought brandon smith has a
pitch for the partridge family dad ready
the dad was the pilot that killed buddy
holly and richie valencia jesus
so there's a musical connection you see
that's how they know reuben
[Laughter]
kids i'm so sorry i know a lot of people
like partridge family jokes you [ __ ]
dads yes we are dads listen this show
was going great it only did 20 minutes
from the [ __ ] portrait family
[ __ ] tim o'brien calls it the
darkridge family
nice
all right
back to hit the murder blood nick back
to the uh to the question jc what was it
uh what would you title the james bond
movie starring yourself
so if you were to be james bond what
would the name of the bond movie be
no time to diet
oh
that's nice
sorry let me
nice dropping of mike
took a while a lot of lot of shoe
leather on that [ __ ] a lot of prop
work i'm like air though except i don't
have the arms
no time to diet
that's pretty good
um
i
let me tell you something here's a quick
pitch while you're thinking about it
yeah yeah
third act turns out reuben is the father
it all ties in you know he's [ __ ] of
course i like your song because it's his
[ __ ] son
and mom has had amnesia like the last 10
years she just don't tell the kids
because she likes it hot like that
where she pretends she don't know this
[ __ ] guy even though it's their
father
or has she not told reuben that he's the
father
you suddenly like and so it's a big
surprise for reuben
oh even reuben's [ __ ] shocked yeah
it's like wait these are my children so
going back she used to like her and
reuben were a thing and she had five
children that she hid from reuben
i mean she was married at the time you
know and they would have the little
thing and she would get pregnant but
they're all [ __ ] redheaded children
and her husband is a black dude
this departure is just like i don't know
i mean this is weird
are they gonna get darker than this
put them on the sun
wow
um
[ __ ]
i don't know i'm drawing a complete
blank on what my james bond movie
would be
um and then my puns are getting
increasingly shitty
um
none of them are going to be no time to
diet um for two reasons that's really
good and b was too fast
um
bernard
oh
uh i'll i'll fill some time in the chat
we had somebody who said uh too high to
die
and also
the smoking gun
oh that's nice very nice
very nice wow
mark yours what you do is just say
someone you don't want to credit those
[ __ ] brilliant rights i moved it was
going too fast
i'm trying to think uh from even even
todd is asking a pretty decent question
hey kev what are you happy about today
do i seem
happy
i mean
baseline happy you don't seem like
extraordinarily so yeah i didn't think i
felt anymore i mean unless you are and
you're just keeping it tight
i i think i'm generally kind of uh
kind of in an up mood and stuff
um but thank you for noticing i am happy
i i was having a good time mark
legitimately said something that made me
[ __ ] laugh and i'm not just talking
about like i'm laughing because that's
well put together like
[ __ ] that critical race
genius [ __ ] [ __ ] man you don't think
i'm gonna rock that joke someplace else
in the world
somebody wrenches critical race theory
to me i'm going to be like [ __ ] yeah
man i like johnny much better than
[ __ ] race
[ __ ] that old man with white hair
you got it
cool
like that's not what critical race
theory is i'm like really i thought it
just meant we were like critical of race
bannon
also i'm not a big nascar fan let me
tell you why
um
okay i got it i got it okay
black diamonds are forever
oh
nice
nice it took me a while what does
bernardin mean was the translation is it
rose or something no uh i don't i don't
think it has a direct translation it's
it's an italian name that had gotten
bernard
and then my theory which has proven
based on nothing more than speculation
is that there's an italian merchant who
left
venice
why not it made its way to france
settled there
you know francis the name so it went
from ben nadine to belmont
and then
but i don't know what the name means
like i've just seen it on like i
remember going to the duomo in florence
big ass church
and there's a bunch of [ __ ] like
bernardinis up on the wall as you know
patriots of the church in
you know 1723 or whatever the [ __ ] it
was
i don't know what it means
my name is don't mean [ __ ] anybody out
there anybody in the chat like oh what
are you guys dumb bernard means
translated means this
yeah
or somebody who's gone to the internet
and did that quick bit of research that
i have not done in 49 years
um we're always a little
behind in chat so we'll catch up to that
in a second yes banff man
z howard 1992 said marked for death
ah that's [ __ ] good man everybody's a
better writer than us
um
francisco
villapando says not to be too far off
topic but bubba wallace won a nascar
race only the second african american to
win
good for him
yeah i'm not a race guy but like
i'm all for history
yeah kenneth c racks said the spy who
loved george
felia
dovefoot says vaccination your policy or
the venue you are appearing at
well here in this house this current
venue
we promote vaccination
we're all back here if you wanted to
come into my house a vaccination would
be required
i don't know what other venue you're
talking about banff man
jump in here and now tell what is the
what are you doing over there at uh
scum and villainy what's your policy so
the recommended guideline is uh by
thursday
for
uh restaurants
so bars as of thursday bars and other
places
in the city of los angeles
uh
i'm sorry jason sporties and chat said
nascar race theory
it's not that critical back to you
critical
that's very serious when you're like
they don't go fast enough or
they go too [ __ ] fast for me
actually critical nascar race theory
would be like do there have to be so
many advertisements
it's like they're moving billboards
so as of thursday bars
are required uh you're required to be
vaccinated going to bars in los angeles
um and other
bar type venues we have a loophole
because we're a restaurant
but i think
we've always tried to do whatever the
the
recommended cdc guidelines are so i i
believe we will be going to vax vaccine
only
by november it'll be
be across the board yeah
santiago bernard in chat said my last
name is actually similar to mark and i
was told that bernard was from germany
it comes from the word bear
which means
bear
maybe it's bear man maybe it's mark bear
man yeah i mean i i could very well have
gone the wrong way which is it could
have been a sort of gallic
um sort of germanic name that you know
much of france and germany were kind of
the same place for a very long time
and uh and the name of bernard meaning
bear then went from that region into
rome
uh into italy given the fact that
[ __ ] caesars conquered most of that
land mass anyway so
leandro sepulveda says bernadini means
strong as a bear or brave bear
and there you have it maybe that mean
maybe your name means strong as a bear
or a brave bear you're a brave bear mark
i'm a brave bear hell yeah i'm gonna go
to san francisco i'm gonna clean up
um all right what else we got we got
another question and first name means
warlike
mark means warlike yeah after the god of
war mars
mars so weird i don't think of how many
marks have started wars
mark anthony had some [ __ ] to do not the
singer but the because i'm sure i'm mark
anthony
he had some [ __ ] to do as well
started a war for people's hearts
um all right what do we got uh
what do we got all right last one
question three
is from orange 2591
i
if somebody made a biopic for fat man
beyond what actor would kevin choose for
mark what actor would mark choose for
kevin and bonus points if they cast jc
but i think we should also cast nate and
andrew as well
oh fair enough
um
mark
is denzel washington oh the sweetest
version of that could you imagine denzel
doing mark
okay okay we're gonna talk about the
snyder verse okay
that snyder didn't land on us we landed
on zack snyder don't do the voice
no you can do the um
um
what do you think
denzel is
mark
jc is matt smith
oh okay some of that [ __ ]
the crown and [ __ ] doctor
audience coming in
nate darknate
gonzalez let's see
david byrne
wow i was going mclovin but nate's gonna
oh well i was gonna say nate's gonna
love david byrne i'm sure he'd be
[ __ ]
insulted by [ __ ] mclovin
i went denzel with you you gave him
[ __ ]
well
i mean let's be honest
it's a it's a character actor part
andrew i got the perfect andrew ready jc
look at me look at me in the eyes and
you tell me if i'm [ __ ] wrong
kurt russell
oh kurt russell would be good i was
going to go david harbor
oh that's a good poll too i was going
bradley cooper i was going like uh like
um what you call it [ __ ] the singing
movie
wow that's three [ __ ] vastly
different polls
for andrew which shows you what an
enigma the man is and three different
ways that we all see him with three very
strong filters
um mine what about you mark um i feel
like
there's a there's a bit of
robert forster
maybe
there's like there's like a
what
robert forster from
mark
[ __ ] jerry bear bail bonds yeah
there's like a real 70s character actor
thing that you that you got going on
me you
you look at me and you see max cherry
from [ __ ] jackie brown i see a young
max cherry yeah i mean i thought we were
going temporarily because [ __ ]
andrew is not a 75 year old russell he's
it's the spirit of the thing
we're we're we're nominalizing the
temporal place and then i was going to
do right now i'm not fighting it i've
just never heard robert forrester in my
entire life
fair enough there's a bit of demiro in
there also i'm not trying to point you
in any direction mark but chat keeps
saying robert downey jr i i'd prefer
that but
you're casting
you're casting denzel [ __ ] man denzel
when i get robert forester
i
didn't i blow your mind this time come
on you you really did um
i think there's some duo in there
i will not argue with uh
with matt smith
oh you know it would be really good for
nate the small chin
oh dave despalchen that's good
he'd do he'd do nate differently than
even nate does nate yeah so what is that
me
why is he in a mirror um
i like that somebody up here said i
thought this was very good um
chickenmonkey33 said kevin james
and reginald veljohnson
that is the version that goes straight
to own
that's the cbs version
[Laughter]
that's the spectrum television presents
fat man beyond
um
blaze melandra who's we've heard from a
few times tonight off topic but i think
ethan sipley should play ben grimm the
thing if they go that age range for
fantastic four
she's not wrong
yeah he'd be great and he's building a
big [ __ ] like ethan's [ __ ] massive
but he also has that real fun sweet
demeanor too just like the thing
good pole man
plug for my for my homeboy
willem black himself
uh is that it we answered all those
questions jc we're out of the question
bag is empty
banff uh questions are empty
russell cook [ __ ] listen to this
timothy chalamet and michael b jordan
i mean
that's the
people that come see fat man beyond
that's the version you cast right there
yeah
yeah
or
chris rock and ben affleck
uh
darth smirnoff said melissa mccarthy is
kev she could play anyone
and meryl streep is mark
i mean that was she that would be
problematic for meryl streep now tiffany
haddish on the other hand oh
nice i feel like we're getting home you
watch
look i'm going to coin a phrase right
here mark but i think she ready
i feel like the gender bent fat man
beyond is the way to go i think so too
they've seen the guy version
melissa mccarthy and viola davis let's
do this
um
so there it is kids
that's it
we got no more show for you showed
everything we could show you
and now the show's over um for those of
you who are like clerks three news um
we're having a friends and family
screening on thursday two days from now
jc will back me up he's the assistant
editor
um we're uh
that's still on correct
still on you haven't changed the movie
since we last talked ever
from
like last week
since the last screening but definitely
since the last screening it's ten
minutes shorter yeah yeah okay yeah you
came and got that when you got the 135
yeah
uh not since then but i should actually
look at it like one more time before we
go just in case like i
put in a lot of temp but i know one or
two places are dry but so far they seem
to be working so i don't know but i'll
i'll i'm gonna watch it again i've left
it alone
for a few days just like you know my mom
and dad told me when i was a kid about
my dick leave it alone for a few days
would you so i left the movie alone i
didn't play with it for a few days but
i'm getting ready to play with it again
because i love it so [ __ ] much
somebody in chat you know was like i
think kevin's happy because clerks
three's in the can and they're
absolutely [ __ ] right like not only
is it in the can um which is like yeah
we finished a thing but it [ __ ]
turned out so good so beautiful like
funny as [ __ ] but really like meaningful
really human so i can't wait for people
to see it but
uh some people are gonna see it on
thursday so next week i'll be able to
let you know
how that went if i cut if i'm not this
happy next week guess what screening
went bad
um i think that's all that's going on
for this [ __ ] week for this edition
fat man beyond man did you have a good
time well if you did that's because jc
made it all possible he put us out here
on these interwebs and stuff
bamf man himself if you want to give
banff man a thanks pop by his [ __ ]
bar man throw back some of them blue
milks chase them with hater tots and
[ __ ] oh
good [ __ ] time what's coming up at
the bar this week anything cool beyond
just like getting drunk
uh
nothing this week the only thing i
really got going on outside of uh the
clerk's screening is at the end of the
month i'm defending my
schmodown fcl star wars belt on the
well done
if you guys want to watch me answer star
wars questions for an hour
i would watch that
am i allowed to bamf in when you do it
and make comments
be fine
that would be all right
um that's cool what about you mark you
got anything to plug uh this week no
no but next week
um i think we're back in the cantina
and uh and
tickets or hey do me a favor jc put uh
tickets up on sale like asap
so that people could start buying them
hey kids you wanna come see
fat man beyond hey hey you wanna look at
something can i show you something i'm
gonna show you me and [ __ ] mark
bernardin as played by somebody
suggested right here
levar burton says thomas zera oh well
done
right that's rather touching as well um
and i would be patrick stewart
you would
make it so no i'd be [ __ ] number one
i'd be was will is it no
i can't believe i pulled that out of my
sitting on chairs all [ __ ] up
yeah will reicher definitely in the
later seasons when the suit
this you know the jumpsuit started
getting a little thicker and stuff he
became a director very much so
he's a big-time tv director huge and
didn't he direct one of the [ __ ] star
treks as well uh first contact yeah
it's good
that's a good one that's a really cool
flick yeah
um but yes we will be back in the
canteen next week um we will have a
guest for the show next week zooming in
from the east coast
scott snyder get out of here comic book
writer scott snyder comic book writer
extraordinaire scott snyder will be our
guest on yield fat man beyond um is he
doing it the goodness of his heart is he
plugging something he's plugging
something he's plugging scoptober
which is the beginning of his cycle of
original uh comic books for comixology
originals look at that man oh he's doing
a comixology original thing he's doing
like five minutes
[ __ ] hey man yeah
he's still at dc though right doing a
batman stuff he's still doing some
batman stuff but he's spreading his
wings he's getting some of that career
create her own robert kirkman thing
where he's like [ __ ] working for the big
two i work for [ __ ] the big one
and that big one is a [ __ ]
multi-billionaire
are you sure that turkmenistan
he he fuels his home
in the winter by burning
huge stacks
of thousand dollar bills
that he'll never spend because there's
not enough time in this lifetime to
spend that walking dead money no that's
just the comic book never mind the
[ __ ] tv version
yeah
there comes
if i ever have to die mark
i won't come back as robert kirkman
right now
there comes a time kevin when
jewels cease to sparkle when gold
loses its luster
the throne becomes a prison and all that
remains
is a man's love for his comic books
there's a man who wants to be robert
kirkman
like in body shape we got the beard
thing down and [ __ ] but
the only difference is he's talented and
i'm me
so close
yet so far far away
so close as vim vendors once taught us
indeed
uh hey kids do you enjoy this [ __ ]
silly ass show well if you do thank the
guy over there man uh there ain't no
show
without the magical mr mark bernardin
oh thank you sir and that ladies and
gentlemen
is fat man beyond for this week i'm
kevin smith and i am mark bernard you
better tune in next week go buy some
tickets right now on eventbrite.com
we'll wait
no you do it after what's over you go
get those tickets we're gonna see you at
the scum and villainy cantina next week
live and if you can't be there you watch
us here on this little internet box man
seems to work out just fine
uh tune in next week
same
fat time same fat channel smodcast.com
or
youtube.com kevin center murder blooding
everybody jeff's kiss
[Applause]
[Music]
you